[Applaudissements]
au tout début de son discours
célébration parce que la province se
porte beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui qu'il y
a quelques années a-t-il affirmé
de pommes de terre en presque du blé
l'année dernière l'économie a repris de
la vigueur il y a une forte croissance
démographique et la dette a diminué à
expliquer le Premier ministre
visiblement très fier de son bilan
[Applaudissements]
l'humeur joyeuse de blending était
contagieuse les 800 personnes venues
l'écouter à Frédéric tonne Henry avec
lui il faut dire qu'il a pas mal laissé
de côté les dossiers plus épineux qui
plombe son gouvernement c'est quoi ton
but what
celui du programme de l'immersion
française par exemple qu'il veut abolir
dès septembre et c'est une décision que
près de 1000 par an et enseignant ont
décrié lors de consultations publiques
il n'a rien dit sur les langues
officielles un dossier qui a créé
beaucoup de tension avec les
francophones de la province mais il a
relancé l'idée d'exploiter le gaz de
schiste la dernière tentative il y a
plusieurs années avait mené à une
révolte des populations acadiennes et
autochtones
il faut saisir l'opportunité maintenant
on ne peut pas attendre a-t-il expliqué
aux journalistes parce que l'Europe est
prête à acheter notre gaz
et sur cette chanson et ces quelques pas
de danse blending a fait comprendre aux
gens dans la salle qu'il n'allait rien
dire sur son avenir politique alors
qu'en septembre il disait qu'une annonce
sans doute
je ne suis pas prêt à prendre cette
décision
l'échelle de l'opposition n'ont pas
apprécié l'incertitude que l'esplaner le
premier ministre ce n'est pas un joke
Premier ministre notre province et je
pense qu'il devait reprendre le travail
un petit peu plus sérieux
mais le Premier ministre ne s'est pas
attiré que des critiques
semble donc en scène pour l'instant il
dit avoir du temps les prochaines
élections provinciales auront lieu dans
un an et demi ici Michel Bridou
Radio-Canada manque